during their one-day informal meeting in
Brussels european union leaders
cautiously welcomed the ukrainian
ceasefire agreement reached in minsk the
President of the European Council Donald
disk stress that what is now on paper
needs to translate into reality on the
ground we are very cautious because
after bad experiences with so-called
miss Kwon it's it's obvious that you
have to be very cautious and of course
our trust in goodwill of President Putin
is limited the fight against terrorism
was also on the agenda following the
attacks in Paris in January will
cooperate together to face this threat
not with emotional overreaction but with
calm and determination we have a great
of new priorities in the fight against
terrorism what is needed most if
agreement on the exchange of passenger
records within records within the
European Union we need the sole EU
leaders agreed more could be done under
the existing rules to step up checks on
travelers entering or leaving the
passport free Schengen zone there was
also discussion on how to improve
economic policy in the eurozone the main
focus was on reinforcing structural
reforms and deepening the economic and
monetary union although the council did
not debate Greece the head of the
Eurogroup briefed the leaders on the
ongoing discussions ahead of next
Monday's key Eurogroup meeting regarding
the country's debt